Last week I posed a question regarding nicotine patches, IV applications, IV cancer,
that you weren't familiar but said you'd look and do it, happy on the opportunity to do so.
I haven't had an opportunity to do a deep dive.
Of course, you can't find anything on the internet, Google about this except negative things about nicotine.
I haven't got a chance to dive into alternative approaches to that.
I would think that it's working on an oxidative stress issue because at least my understanding of everything that's out there research-wise nicotine is it causes oxidative stress.
So, you know, just a side note about that, you know, that gets into should a cancer patient take antioxidants.
I think I talked about it the last week, Zoom call, somebody asked a question about should all breast cancer patients be on blue and I said, no, absolutely not.
Blue to thiode is one of your strongest intercellular antioxidants.
And you know, what chemo does is it works as an oxidizing agent to kill cancer cells because cancer cells.
Because they're rapidly replicated, they're not producing adequate amounts of blue to thiode so they're more susceptible to reactive oxygen species, oxidative stress, any oxidative agents.
And that's why chemo can kill that directly.
So, when you're just taking a whole bunch of antioxidants, you could be supporting the life of cancer cell.
So, it's all about balance with oxidative stress slash antioxidant to block oxidative stress.
Oxidative stress can cause cancer antioxidants can prevent that oxidative stress cause of cancer.
Once a person has cancer, an oxidative therapy, maybe once in the best interest.
I mean, that's how lateral works be 17. That's how cortisol works. That's how some other therapies works as they stimulate oxidative stress or stimulate production of reactive oxygen species. They're actually the cancer.
So, no, not that everybody shouldn't be on high dose of the antioxidants. So, I think that is the mechanism of action with the nicotine is usually as an oxidative stress agent.
So, it could be wrong, but I think that sort of makes the most sense for my, that amount of extremities.